also tritt begleiten ihrem leben ist ein
einziger lebensinhalt ist mit massiven
arminia eigenen filmen meine eigene
interessen auf
es ist aber so dass mich das wirklich
zufrieden macht und mich erfüllt das
glücklich sind mit den eltern von home
school investieren viel zeit in die
bildung ihrer kinder und provozieren bei
normalen eltern damit zuverlässig
ablehnung
dabei sind auch holmes coole eltern
nicht frei von bedenken
es ist auch mehr durststrecke mit vielen
ängsten verbunden und auch ohne den
druck spürt zur visite vom system oder
so die behörde
ich muss und ich finde jetzt machen
die material suchen
sutil hofft am sonntag
doch das irgendwie nie so genannte junge
und das ist aber die maxime monfort
pathologisch werden
er hat auch der lastzug und sagen macht
mal was los ist wichtig das vertrauen
wächst wenn man sich mit solchen themen
auseinandersetzt
dann entsteht ein gewisses unbehagen ich
weiß es ist nicht angenehm aber ich
glaube genau in diesem unbehagen was das
neue schule nicht schule und so weit ist
glaube ich eine zwei trainings fast
geografischer fast organisatorische
frage das ist eine sache der haltung und
ich glaube es muss uns wirklich bewusst
werden dass in der haltung überall
umsetzbar ist geht darum was man an ein
für allemal dem kind das gefühl die dort
eine gewisse haltung
ich gebe ein grünes licht deinem wesen
so wie du bist bist du perfekt und das
ist das einzige was meine eltern nicht
mehr gegeben haben
die sind immer noch da ob sie
geografisch anwesend oder nicht sind und
geben mir das gefühl du bist die
richtige person am richtigen ort zur
richtigen zeit
[Musik]